hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space - oh where where
oh you ha ha Oh gotcha crouching hell
I'll show you like 10 billion times ah
okay that I just that's just piss me off
not a good way to start an episode
whatever you wanna what the frickin
front happened he was gone on the
railing guy stays as him I shot him
three times right in the arm it didn't
come up
maybe his because he was caught in an
animation it didn't allow him to fall
off I don't know don't trust any of you
good that shield how quickly do these
things research lon four three five four
six Express physical representation of
the heuristic algorithm summation for
okay break down the construction
schedule begins in earnest tomorrow so
all the stores broken hope I don't black
out in the middle of the party I just
for some reason yeah you're all crazy
you're all marker crazy all right what
the heck am i doing okay sack station
they just not give is that one broken
just because I'm a hard no doesn't want
to give me a store or something I don't
know but whatever
it's read in here
well I hear babies hi-c babies but that
hotel
are you just laying there weird
ah Wow
wanna blow it up blow it the [ __ ] up you
gotta be [ __ ] me
dodge you wherever you are I mean whoa
okay Joe got some quick now
ah what the hell what the [ __ ] seriously
oh you gotta be kidding me
get the gun um very dead
you've got to be joking me what the [ __ ]
just never mind screw everything screw
everything about that that is [ __ ]
Santa's over here so it doesn't go off
waste that [ __ ]
No oh come on
right what the hell who's aimed right at
mother [ __ ]
you
and now no one are you good the [ __ ] are
you doing down there
shut up
no [ __ ] don't care about you anything
about you just die are you kidding me
huh it's [ __ ] Dale pile of people's
steaming pile you [ __ ]
of course I use some line go on
there goes doesn't matter nothing
matters
the other things those ones right right
there remind me of the enemies from
either crime fear afraid of monsters its
ears that there twitches class
when the dye nope miss me [ __ ]
God [ __ ] you God how many are there
you're still alive
come here are you got ya oh nice it
pissed me off to no end that ah more you
gotta be joking you're joking
[ __ ] joke
like that and popping there we go
at least when I'm pissed off I get a
little better at the game I see you
man how many did they throw at me like
this is this is an an incredible step up
in the number of in the amount of
[ __ ] they've thrown in my way they're
still coming
seriously why I'm out of ammo almost
across the board I'm out of ammo
oh no I've got I've got plasma energy
now wants to pick it up because I swear
I ran out of that one and I'm out a
flamethrower rammer now no I can't throw
that at you another one and you're not
going there I got to get better at
picking up this sometimes it just wants
to pick up a random body pardon if I'm
if there's one charging straight at me
and I got a random leg in my hands
there's not much that that's gonna do me
oh don't tell me this is gonna be
another floor of that [ __ ]
or maybe they'll know if it's another
one well kana [ __ ] reuse this I feel
take that while I look around no one up
there gonna drop one damn
what the [ __ ] got caught on something
joking me no said no
do not shut up you should a there oh my
god
I swear
another one come here [ __ ]
what's up give me your I see what it
mean I know he's got another one nope
nope
[ __ ] Elvis slowing
[ __ ] [ __ ] just died are you joking oh
man it's just so [ __ ] many of them
god I guess I don't even know if the
doors locked at the end maybe I
should've gone through instead of
fighting him how am I supposed to know
not to stand there and fight them anyway
oh one big [ __ ] everyone knows
how much I love fluster [ __ ]
I got Wow I got a couple of med kits at
least that's something anyway what else
is new in 10th [ __ ] Emile research log
for I feel for 9 ok I blacked out early
last night and woke up this morning
staring at a tiny fully formed version
of the marker in one of the crystal er
cutting back ok algorithm I can still
hear it in my mind like a song then
you're crazy I know that dementia
suppressors are working on but this is
something entirely different
no it's not
oh I don't care anything nothing
oh hello
and a Bumpus
if that show
still not dead
burn-up joke shut up and burn yes thank
you for dying only a ruby I've had one
of you give me a give me a diamond
before haven't I think I had am i clear
alright go let it go yep yep yep
okay finally out of that oh my god they
must have taken away that one store from
me just because I'm on a harder
difficulty and they wanted to see me go
through all of that without a store man
if I didn't have ammo going into that I
would have been totally screwed oh hello
little one creeping Oh another one
Oh down there - holy crap that's
actually kind of cool they're all going
this way
why awfully big place okay I don't see
any goodies all right
project inner core
yeah but I mean there's not much other
way to go
hello ah store thank you Oh Tex law haha
private communication from overseer tied
minh disappointed in the evacuation
decision consequences will be dire that
is all I guess someone was not supposed
to evacuate why probably just not to get
the infection out okay I've got way too
many of these things
I got like almost sell this so this more
flame and lots lots of plasma energy
I barely filling up any of my storage so
I'm just gonna go all out on the plasma
that's it
and lots of flick flame fuel does come
very useful sometimes I'm not gonna be
caught with my pants down again without
ammo they fit one more flavor and then
some AB powder okay make it my way
I'll bench something big must be coming
up but I don't know if it'll be any
worse than what I just went through so
bring it on letting it cool save yeah
definitely there's something coming up
all right what you got for me an
elevator the world's lowest elevator you
the AIESEC dance yeah the odds of dance
rock from side to side
hard enough that silliness
Oh 94m oh whoa whoa
whoa oh oh my god I don't you are an
engineer extraordinaire holy damn when I
said they had something big for me I
didn't know I meant this uh-huh what the
hell what are you doing
they're all coming to the marker
convergence is at hand mister they told
me you are necessary okay that your mind
was the purest all right years I think
you wanted me to brain this is nothing
it was supposed to end how is it
supposed to happen timing control Clark
this is not our fault
hello he's gonna blow those bodies in
here
but we never it
okay what it was made to do Isaac you
have to make us whole no I won't I'm
gonna destroy that sombitch
I'm gonna destroy it dead
nice lady damn look at that
my helmets off look how handsome I am
that's actually I gotta destroy it in
the next episode because I am all out of
time
thank you guys so much for watching and
as always see you in the next one bye
bye